[Musique]
nouvelle édition de l'entretien
politique sur tv 78 merci de nous
rejoindre en cours du prochain quart
d'heure c'est avec jean-noël barrot
député modem des yvelines que nous
allons échanger bonjour jean noël barrot
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour
débuter vous est donc vice président de
la commission des finances face aux
difficultés rencontrées aujourd'hui par
les français pour payer leurs factures
d'énergie pour remplir le réservoir de
leur véhicule aussi la réponse du
gouvernement est elle la bonne les
chèques énergie par exemple cela suffit
écoutez d'abord simplement rappelé que
contrairement à ce qui avait pu se
passer lors des quinquennats précédent
le président de la république et la
majorité ont tenu leur engagement tout
au long du mandat s'agissant du pouvoir
d'achat nous avons pc et même supprimer
la taxe d'habitation nous avons baissé
les cotisations sur le travail nous
allons baisser l'impôt sur le revenu
elle tout cela c'était des engagements
qui avaient été pris devant les français
aujourd'hui nous sortons de la crise
avec une croissance qui est
particulièrement forte en france mais
qui est forte partout ailleurs dans le
monde et une flambée des prix de
l'énergie le gouvernement a réagi très
fortement avec d'abord un chèque énergie
avec un blocage des prix du gaz et puis
la semaine dernière avec une indemnité
inflation 200 euros pour la moitié des
français pour plus de la moitié de
français en réalité ces chèques sont une
bonne réponse il ya pas eu de baisse de
taxes par exemple pour le carburant
je crois que c'est la bonne réponse
effectivement parce que d'abord sa cible
pas seulement le carburant mais le reste
de des prix qui aujourd'hui
demande que par ailleurs il vaut mieux
apporter un complément de pouvoir
d'achat sous la forme d'un chèque plutôt
que des bouts de baisser les taxes qui
aurait eu un effet moindre et qui par
ailleurs serait un peu contraire à la
politique qu'on a voulu mener depuis le
début du quinquennat c'est à dire de
constater ou en tout cas de mettre tout
en oeuvre pour
sortir le plus rapidement des énergies
fossiles et ça ça suppose aussi que
les énergies alternatives puissent
devenir plus compétitives et quand on
baisse les taxes sur le carburant lui
vient d'une certaine manière on en
désavantage les autres énergies les
énergies renouvelables notamment mais
quitte à oublier peut-être aussi les
classes moyennes parce que c'est elle
qu'on entend aussi le plus elles sont
appelées les oubliés de toutes ces
mesures d' aides qui peuvent être
annoncées dont elles sont les grands
gagnants du quinquennat macron pendant
lequel le pouvoir d'achat a augmenté
deux fois plus vite que lors des deux
quinquennats précédent et notamment pour
les classes moyennes cette intervention
l'ajustement de souligner que les
classes moyennes et que le pouvoir
d'achat avait progressé vous l'avez fait
récemment à l'assemblée nationale pardon
néanmoins pourquoi ce sentiment tout de
même deux des français que les choses ne
vont pas forcément mieux pour leur
portefeuille c'est très simple il ya
deux manières d'améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat la première c'est de réduire
pardon c'est de faire progresser le
revenu après impôt à la fin du mois et
ça c'est ce à quoi le gouvernement et la
majorité s'est employé depuis 2010 est
avec une progression du revenu après
impôt du niveau de vie après impôts qui
deux fois plus rapide que sous les deux
cassettes quinquennat précédent et puis
ensuite il faut faire baisser le coût de
la vie et ça ça suppose notamment de
donner un coup de pouce lorsque on
constate une flambée des prix mais plus
généralement d'agir de manière plus
structurelle pour faire baisser le coût
de l'énergie notamment et ça c'est la
stratégie du gouvernement notamment en
matière de de développement des énergies
renouvelables et de développement de
l'énergie nucléaire vous appartenez au
modem je leur précise le modem va
continuer à travailler main dans la main
avec le gouvernement sur la fin de ce
mandat et même préparer les prochaines
échéances électorales ensemble oui bien
sûr nous sommes depuis 2010 est aux
côtés d' emmanuel macron nous avons
pleinement
participé à la fois au gouvernement et
au parlement à l'effort de réforme à la
réponse à la crise lorsqu'elle est
survenu et donc nous continuerons de le
faire dans cet esprit là je parle des
prochaines échéances électorales
plusieurs des député des yvelines ont
annoncé leur volonté ou pas de briguer
un nouveau mandat est ce que ce sera
votre cas en 2022 je suis pleinement
occupés d'abord à à l'assemblée
nationale a essayé de de traiter les
problèmes du quotidien des français on
évoqua l'instant la question du coût de
la vie on est en train de débattre du
budget de l'état et du budget de la
sécurité sociale et puis en parallèle
pour les yvelines et dans ma
circonscription à faire avancer les
choses jusqu'au dernier moment sur la
question notamment des mobilités et des
nuisances sonores donc c'est ça qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui
proposerait pas vous ne proposez pas
encore la question d'un nouveau mandat
en tout cas pas officiellement je me
pose la question de la manière dont je
peux améliorer la mobilité dans ma
circonscription et réduire les nuisances
sonores que ce soit dans la vallée de
chevreuse ou que ce soit aux alentours
de toussus le noble alors pro parlons
justement de vos actions sur sur le sur
la circonscription sur votre
circonscription il ya plusieurs dossiers
il ya aussi ce dossier delà de la
pollution sonore par exemple en vallée
de chevreuse qui dure depuis des années
sur lequel vous êtes intervenu aussi est
ce qui aura des avancées significatives
encore dans les prochains mois oui il va
y avoir des avancées significatives
puisque en principe on devrait dans les
toutes prochaines semaines installez les
les premiers radars sonore automatique
pour les expérimentés pendant quelques
mois avant qu'il puisse être
véritablement
actif est susceptible de verbaliser des
des niveaux sonores excessifs c'est un
sujet sur lequel je travaille depuis
quatre ans avec les élus de la vallée de
chevreuse et qui devrait donc trouver
son premier aboutissement très
prochainement en espérant que ça puisse
apporter l'une par une réponse un
élément de réponse à ce problème qui
empoisonne la vie des riverains déroute
de la veille et sur la fin de ce mandat
vos priorités votre priorité
sur la circonscription bien cc2 de
poursuivre le travail engagé à la fois
avec les riverains les usages et les
services de l'état sur la question de de
la réduction des nuisances sonores de
l'aérodrome de toussus le noble la
réduction des nuisances sonores en
vallée de chevreuse et puis
l'amélioration plus généralement des
mobilités que ce soit dans le lac sud
nord en provenance de la vallée de
chevreuse vers la ville nouvelle mais
aussi sur les mobilités ferrée dans le
nord de la circonscription ce que mon
moment je dirais mon mandat
d'administrateur à ile-de-france
mobilité me permet désormais de faire
avec peut-être un peu plus d'efficacité
j'en reviens tout de même parce que on
arrive sur une fin de mandat et on l'a
bien compris encore des dossiers à
traiter l'heure n'est pas encore aux
élections néanmoins ça occupe beaucoup
l'actualité ne serait ce que national
aussi toutes ces discussions comment
vous vous regardez aujourd'hui les
débats qui peuvent porter sur la montée
des extrêmes sur la participation elle
est toujours la question de l'abstention
sur les prochains mois il faut aussi
remobiliser un électorat pour qu'ils ne
se tournent pas vers les extrêmes
oui alors je ne suis pas certain que ça
passionne les les françaises et les
français qui ont bien conscience qu'ils
viennent de traverser une crise
absolument historique à la fois sur le
plan sanitaire mais aussi sur le plan
économique
qu'on a quelques indices qui dès qu'ils
suggèrent que l'épidémie pourrait
repartir dans les prochaines semaines et
les prochains mois que même si la
croissance est forte les entreprises en
compte deux des difficultés de
recrutement considérable des difficultés
d'approvisionnement qui font monter les
prix et c'est donc je crois que c'est
sont ses sujets qui préoccupent
principalement les français ensuite on
voit se développer effectivement
ddd tentation
populiste sur la scène politique et donc
nous les combattrons gelé combattrait en
expliquant ce que nous avons fait la
manière dont nous traitons ou dont nous
avons traité et nous comptons continuer
de traiter les questions de
réchauffement climatique les questions
d'insécurité les questions d'immigration
des questions de laïcité sur lesquels
beaucoup de choses ont été faites
pendant ce quinquennat évidemment nous
n'avons pas toutes achevées et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense qu'il faut
que
emmanuel macron soit de nouveau candidat
à l'élection présidentielle pour coque
lors d'un second quinquennat nous
puissions aller jusqu'au bout de ce que
nous voulions faire pour le pays vous
souhaitez qu'il se prononce rapidement
sur sa candidature emmanuel macron
écoutez c'est une décision qui lui qui
lui appartient c'est lui qui sait le
mieux le moment
le plus approprié pour devenir candidat
sans pour autant renoncer évidemment
être le président de tous les français
et et de gérer notre pays qui se
retrouve comme je le disais à l'instant
dans une dans une situation qui est
évidemment plus favorable que celle que
nous connaissions il ya quelques mois
mais qui reste très fragile j'en reviens
tout de même une dernière question sur
cette question de la politique nationale
qui rejoint aussi celle du département
eric zemmour pour le site et était
présent dans le département des yvelines
à versailles pour la troisième fois en
quelques mois je crois comment vous vous
regardez ce déplacement sur ce bassin
yvelinois où il espère un petit peu
engranger des voix et faire campagne si
notamment du côté de versailles
moi je ce que je constate c'est que
eric zemmour progresse dans l'opinion en
tout cas c'est ce que les sondages nous
disent et à mon avis là la première
explication à cela c'est c'est que vous
avez à la fois une droite qui est un peu
perdu sa sa boussole qui a qui n'a pas
su lorsqu'elle était en responsabilité
tenir ses promesses je rappelle que lors
du quinquennat des deux de nicolas
sarkozy puisque vous matez rosiers sur
la fiscalité tout à l'heure les
impôts ont été baissés avant d'être
relevé je pense au bouclier fiscal qui a
été mis en place dès les premiers jours
du mandat qui était supprimée ensuite je
pense à l'impression et société qui a
d'abord baissé avant d'être relevé et
donc je pense qu'il ya une droite qui a
perdu une forme de crédit auprès des
français et puis vous avez une extrême
droite
traditionnelle celle de marine le pen
qui elle aussi a fait des volte face
notamment s'agissant de la participation
de la france à la zone euro qui est qui
qui lui a fait perdre à son tour à un
certain crédit auprès des français et
donc vous avez là un nouvel entrant qui
surf une vague populiste et qui peut
être créer un nouvel espoir mais je mets
en garde évidemment la droite
républicaine et celles et ceux qui s'en
réclament parce qu'il ya derrière les
derrières les effets de manche d'eric
zemmour une vision très rétrécit très
étriqué de ce que nous sommes de ce
qu'est la france de ce qu'est l'europe
qui est une voie sans issue merci
beaucoup jean noël barrot d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin pour l'entretien
politique député modem des yvelines à
bientôt sur tv elle soixante dix huit
pour un prochain entretien politique
[Musique]